ميدان الفرح الذي لا نهاية له هو الربيع ، وهذا في الأصل هذا
كان يوجد
زر قاعة المحاضرات والمطر الفضي
رئيس جمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية
الرفيق الرفيق شين جونغ إيل
يجب أن يكون لديك المزيد في المرة القادمة
آه ، أنا في الخامسة من أصل 4 حلقات من Eunbi Jo
المشاركون في العيد طوال النهار والليل الآن 00
اسمع ، صديقي Midian سيفعل ذلك من أجلك.
الذي - التي
عملية جيم سومي للخرز 1 للرفيق
زهور رسمها كيم سيونغ جونغ على سرير المستشفى
هدأت السلة
أوه ، جوسون ، عضو اللجنة المركزية لرئيس مملكة جوسون
مجلس دولة جمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية
خارج المحور الخامس لجمهورية كوريا الشعبية الديمقراطية
اللجنة الدائمة للشعب الفضي احباط جيم سيونغ ايل
أعيش لأعجب بتمثال رفيقي.
أخذت قسطا من الراحة
آه
جونغنو الرقيب عضو اللجنة المركزية الدائرة السياسية للدولة
عضو في اللجنة الديمقراطية الكورية
جمهورية الشعب
أول رئيس للجنة هو المقبرة
المكتب السياسي للجنة المركزية لحزب العمال الكوري
وهو عضو في اللجنة الدائمة و
لا يمكنني رميها بعيدًا 2 الرفيق إيو يونغ هوان
المكتب السياسي للجنة المركزية لحزب العمال الكوري (WPK)
الطريق مستمر ، مكتبة شعب ديمقراطي
يو نائب الرئيس بعد فيلم الجمهورية
يأتي الرفاق بفضل الفريق في تنظيم قيمي
كان التناقض واحد
4 ملاحظات
عمال مناجم البخور ودرجة ومقرها سونج جونج
السيدة Tobacco و 3 Jiwon-san هما المسؤولان فقط
أمير فون وآخرون. الجواب هو 210
قائد الفرقة السادسة رو بيو
نصف مليء سنوات نهر الأخ الجديد
لقد تعبت من الرجيج ، أقول أخيرًا
واو بدون فريق عصير الخيول السوداء
إنه لأمر مضحك إذا كنت تستخدم الحانة مقابل مبلغ معين
باع